good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight they always accuse you
of the very things they're doing
themselves if there's one rule you can
keep on your fridge write it down put it
in your wallet to evaluate the behavior
of the people in charge it's that they
blame you for their sins every single
time
the latest example arrived this week
when we learned that Joe Biden fresh
from lecturing us about how Donald Trump
is a criminal because he had
unauthorized possession of secret
documents that very same Joe Biden
himself had unauthorized possession of
secret documents but don't worry it's
not a big deal unlike you in that
despicably orange Donald Trump Joe Biden
is a good person Joe Biden is so
virtuous he has transcended temporal law
it's not a crime when he does it
so that's the frustratingly familiar
headline from this week's story which
you've probably seen by now but the
details of the story are actually pretty
interesting
so a week before these last midterm
elections Joe Biden's lawyers were for
some reason rooting around in a locked
closet in the Washington office of
something called the Penn Biden Center
for diplomacy and Global engagement
and while in that locks closet Biden's
lawyers found a Sheaf of Highly
classified government documents
so the first question here is why were
Joe Biden's lawyers doing this in the
first place and we can't say for sure
because they haven't told us but it is
weird lawyers don't typically search
locked closets yours probably don't but
Biden's lawyers did and we'd guess they
did because they understood that
Republicans were about to win back the
house and with it Congressional subpoena
power
so they were likely conducting a cleanup
operation preemptively trying to get
ahead of a scandal they knew was coming
and of course they hid what they found
in that closet until after the midterm
elections because there's no reason to
influence voters too much
with information
so there's that
and then there's the question of these
so-called Penn Biden Center at the
University of Pennsylvania what is that
exactly the whole idea of an academic
Biden Center is pretty funny Joe Biden
is a [ __ ] he's always been a [ __ ] even
before the dementia for decades in
Washington ask anyone who lived there
Biden was famous as the dumbest member
of the Senate people made jokes about it
so why would an ivy league university
name a think tank after a man who can't
think and then pay him nearly a million
dollars a year for not doing anything
good question a little more on that in
just a minute
but first a word about classified
documents now this is not a partisan
Point not attacking anybody it's just
the truth
these people you see on television
huffing and puffing about vital State
secrets on both sides by the way not
just Democrats everybody vital State
secrets they're either lying or they
don't really understand how Washington
works
how many legitimate vital State secrets
are there well actually not very many at
all in a democracy the government has no
right to hide what it's doing from the
public except under extraordinary
circumstances
it's fine to classify the Normandy
invasion until it happens it is not fine
to spend 60 years hiding the fact that
the CIA was involved in the murder of a
president
hiding your involvement in the Kennedy
assassination is not a national security
precaution it is Criminal behavior and
it's made possible by a classification
regime that was designed not to protect
this country but to protect and enrich
our permanent political class which it
very efficiently does
oh but our enemies Screech the morons on
TV if we to classify these documents
whatever they are if we do that our
enemies will learn our secrets
please
China already knows our secrets all of
our secrets the Chinese government has
hacked every agency in Washington and
everybody knows that and nobody seems to
care
divide Administration cares so little in
fact it's just suspended a
counter-espionage program designed to
stop Chinese spying
in other words the Chinese can know but
you can't know Biden trusts Beijing more
than he trusts you
so the media's job its only job really
is to push back against attitudes like
that and to seek the truth reporters are
the people who are paid who for a living
find out what your government is doing
and then tell you about it so democracy
can continue
but there are very few of those left
Julian Assange is in prison for his
efforts Ed Snowden lives in Exile
and the News organizations that remain
are so thoroughly controlled by
government agencies that even the
suggestion of more public transparency
drives them to Hysteria watch CNN and
MSNBC for example react to the news that
republicans in Congress might tell us
some of what the thoroughly corrupt
Intel Community has been doing in our
name a house committee where Republicans
can shred at the Integrity of the
federal government and tell America that
your government is spying on you and
coming after you that is at the heart of
this tear down break down the government
we can't trust the government we're
going to topple it he just gave them a
committee platform to have those
hearings and you better believe that is
going to be heroin in the veins of Fox
News viewers over the next two years
basically they're establishing a
subcommittee or a committee on witch
hunts and deep state conspiracy theories
this is so extraordinarily dangerous as
you said they're going to actually these
people want to Target
America's Intel Community this is a body
that of the Congress that we are trying
to maintain credibility with and we are
not going to do that by opening up all
kinds of suspicions about the
institutions in our society
it's outrageous to tell people the
government is spying on them especially
since the government is spying on them
that's confirmed by the way that's a
fact they spite on us
but if you want to know what your
government is doing schools Joe
Scarborough you're quote targeting
America's Intel Community you're
unpatriotic you're a disloyal American
if you don't want to be lied to
that's what they're saying out loud on
MSNBC tonight
in the past few months we have learned
that for years Twitter functioned as a
mouthpiece for the FBI and the spy
agencies clearly the same thing has
happened to cable news and that is a
Graver threat to our democracy than any
group of trump voters who wandered
around the capitol on January 6th it's
not even close
but back to our story and the
hilariously obvious double standard
on the question of classified documents
it was just this Summer that NBC's
hyperventilating house historian Michael
beschlas suggests that Donald Trump
deserved the death penalty for keeping
classified documents at Mar-A-Lago fried
like the rosenbergs in the electric
chair
former CIA director Michael Hayden
agreed sounds about right Hayden wrote
Because at this point is totally normal
for CIA directors to fantasize about
killing American presidents
so just for fun today we reached out to
Michael beschlas to ask what punishment
he thinks Joe Biden deserves for keeping
classified documents in his office
of course Specialists didn't respond to
us he was too busy applying pancake
makeup in his living room for other
MSNBC hit
but to be fair it wasn't just Michael
beschlas who claimed that Trump was
endangering America with those documents
they all said that watch
the seriousness of the Potential Threat
to National Security information I I
just don't know what to say if he was in
possession of classified documents those
are by definition potentially harmful to
our national security we have a
president of the United States who has
played fast and loose with the National
Security we have a situation where what
he was doing was dangerous to our
national security these are really
classified and a really a threat to
National Security that really jumps out
to me as a national security threat this
is a national security crisis the
extreme risk that Trump was willing to
take with our national security
the funniest part was Bernstein formerly
The Washington Post who literally
participated in an FBI operation not
guessing documented an FBI operation to
drive a sitting dually elected president
from Office Carl Bernstein participated
in that and he's lecturing us about how
no we have to keep the secret things
secret
so last night we learned that Joe Biden
someone with no power to declassify
anything when he was vice president
stashed classified documents in the
closet of his private office at the very
same time he was sending the doj after
Donald Trump for doing the same thing
so how exactly are our news media going
to make sense of this well of course
with maximum shamelessness
today CNN trotted out a CIA lawyer
called Brian Greer to explain that
mishandling classified information is no
longer a big deal in fact honestly kids
it happens all the time
almost any mishandling case could
potentially be shoehorned into a
criminal investigation but going back to
my prior point because this type of this
handling happens all the time and now
it's become such a political football
with all three uh last presidential
candidates being investigated I do worry
about why we need to take this all
seriously and it needs to be
investigated I do worry about over
criminalizing it launching these full
investigations that become political
footballs is dangerous because it can
disincentivize people from serving in
the federal government we want it but we
do want to incentivize them again to do
the right thing which is reported when
it happens and not to do the wrong thing
which is to conceal and obstruct which
is what Trump did
some of us who've worked in cable news
for the past 25 years can affirm it
wasn't always the case that every time
you flipped on the tube there was some
CIA or NSA or FBI employee telling you
what the truth is because news
organizations used to assume that if
someone was paid to lie for the
government they probably weren't a
reliable Oracle on TV they probably
weren't telling the truth to viewers but
now it's the norm
so the CIA lawyer you just saw Brian
Greer was telling us just a few months
ago that Donald Trump by doing the same
thing that Biden did endangered quote
National Security
the intelligence agencies Greer said
quote have no choice but to assume a
compromise and take proactive measures
to protect our sources and collection
capabilities
that was then like August now he's
telling you this kind of thing happens
all the time just calm down calm down
the rest the news media has been every
bit as Brazen The Washington Post just
reported that quote the case will likely
draw comparisons to Mar-A-Lago but
appears to be quite different really how
is it quite different
by the way every news source is telling
us there were 10 documents found how do
they know that well of course they don't
know that they have no idea how many
documents were found they're just taking
Biden's lawyer's word for it that's not
news collection
that's press release writing but you
will see identical articles in Forbes
and Business Insider in the hill
the usual places all repeating the same
scripted talking point
now in one sense what those Outlets are
telling you is true Joe Biden we learned
today was not holding on to the kind of
cocktail napkins found at Mar-A-Lago he
had actual classified information about
a bunch of countries including Ukraine
from his time as vice president
why why is it always about Ukraine what
is going on in Ukraine don't talk about
the bio Labs what is that
why the obsession with Ukraine going
back long before the Russian invasion of
Ukraine going back many years
well in this case it turns out that
three days before Joe Biden left his job
as vice president in January of 2017.
the ukrainians were also a little bit
confused about the focus on their
country in mid-January 2017 State
Department officials circulated a report
from Ukraine Forum that's the Ukraine
State media organization and the report
said this and we're quoting literally on
the last days of his term the U.S Vice
President Joe Biden is going to Kiev how
can we explain this attention to us so
even the ukrainians were confused why
is the president of the United States
the world's richest country spending so
much of his life focused on Europe's
poorest country Ukraine what's going on
well here's one explanation at the same
moment
that Joe Biden was visiting Ukraine as
his last official act his drug-addicted
son Hunter was still making tens of
thousands of dollars a month in a
no-show job on the board of barisma the
largest gas company in Ukraine natural
gas something Hunter Biden knew nothing
about
I wonder if I wouldn't hold that fake
job until 2019. so is there a connection
just guessing here between the fact that
his son was getting rich from Ukraine
for a no-show job and Joe Biden's 2017
trip to Ukraine on Air Force 2 at your
expense
you think there might be a connection
but so far no one in Washington has
thought to really press that point
because they're still upset about Trump
they're still talking about Trump and
his crimes
watch Joe Biden from this past September
explain why he supported the doj raid on
Mar-A-Lago and here's a hint because
it's quote totally irresponsible for
government officials to keep classified
documents after leaving office
when you saw the photograph of the top
secret documents laid out on the floor
at Mar-A-Lago what did you think to
yourself
looking at that image
how that could possibly happen how one
anyone could be that irresponsible
and I thought what data was in there
that may compromise sources and methods
by that I mean names of people who
helped or et cetera and it just uh
totally irresponsible
so they seem like Hypocrites we could
play an endless loop of Clips like that
for the rest of the hour you get the
point but they're not actually
Hypocrites what they're describing is a
caste system where they can do what they
want and you are subject to the minutia
of their legal code it's called
anarchot-tyranny
but on to more enduring questions
because we know that already what is
this pen Biden Center the Penn Biden
Center what's the purpose of the Penn
Biden Center well in April of 2016 one
of Hunter Biden's business associates
explained the purpose in an email to
Hunter
he said that the Penn Biden Center quote
operates like the Clinton Global
initiative without the money Rays oh so
all the upside none of the downside
without the money raised really so you
have to fly around the world raising
money but as the Washington Free Beacon
has reported actually there was a lot of
money being raised and it was being
raised by the University of Pennsylvania
and was being raised from foreign
governments after the Biden Center
opened see the connection here and we're
quoting from the piece foreign
contributions the University of
Pennsylvania tripled since the Penn
Biden Center's soft opening in March of
2017 rising from 31 million in 2016 to
over a hundred million in 2019. now
where'd all that money come from
what do you think the largest foreign
contributor was China
and if you go to the web page for the
Penn Biden Center you get some idea of
what that money bought so on the site
there's a section called quote
addressing threats to the liberal
International order
Russia and Vladimir Putin are mentioned
as threats to the liberal International
order but China which is currently
committing genocide is conspicuously not
mentioned as a threat to the liberal
International order
so all this aroused our suspicions
naturally so we decided to get closer
look at the University of Pennsylvania
and its ties to China
we took a look at text messages from
Hunter Biden's laptop to see if we could
find an answer and we found messages
between a senior professor at Penn's
international relations department to
Naomi Biden that would be Hunter Biden's
very young daughter
the message from the professor begins
this way quote dear Naomi I'm writing
you tonight to invite you to take part
in a major conference in China at the
end of March I've been asked to help
recruit a prominent young leader they
the Chinese government will fly you
business class and of course provide all
of your accommodations I don't think it
would surprise you they are interested
interested in you thanks to your family
name I would not take offense at that it
is truly the Chinese way and frankly
better you than that dolt Tiffany Trump
if you're interested can you send me
your CV and or a bio I would forward
that and you could expect an official
invitation from Lee Bao dong the
Secretary General of the Forum end quote
pretty remarkable as far as we know that
has not been previously reported
so here you have an employee of the
University of Pennsylvania an Ivy League
school sending an invitation apparently
on behalf of the Chinese Communist party
to recruit Joe Biden's granddaughter for
an influence operation saying that she'd
be flown to Beijing and stay in Chinese
government-controlled accommodations
so a lot of people on television seem
very concerned about National Security
at the moment all these former CIA and
NSA and FBI employees are going on CNN
MSNBC to tell you National Security
implications are first in mind
are they concerned about this well they
ask a single question about it
of course they won't
so tonight we're going to begin by
asking fact-based questions about those
classified materials that Joe Biden
apparently had at the Penn Biden Center
and what they tell us
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight